[Music]
removal of the appendix called
appendectomy is performed when
appendicitis is suspected right lower
abdominal pain fever and elevated
white-blood-cell count are common
symptoms and signs of appendicitis which
usually occurs when a blockage develops
between the appendix and the intestine
this leads to infections swelling and
distension if the appendix is not
removed it can lead to a
life-threatening perforation or rupture
the most common treatment for
appendicitis is appendectomy which is
almost always performed on an emergency
basis
laparoscopic techniques require only
tiny keyhole incisions or puncture
wounds
to get inside your abdomen your surgeon
will make a small keyhole incision near
your bellybutton known as an umbilical
port with a tube called a trocar
gasps will then be pumped through this
port to puff up your abdomen so its
contents can be viewed more easily next
your surgeon will insert a laparoscope
through this port the laparoscope is a
thin tube with a tiny camera on the end
of it that projects images onto a
monitor to guide your surgeons work
using the laparoscope your surgeon will
examine images of your appendix on the
monitor to confirm that it's red and
swollen if your appendix needs to be
removed additional ports will be created
your surgeon will pass surgical
instruments through these other ports to
grasp the appendix another instrument
will be used to separate the appendix
from the intestine and close the ends
with staples the appendix will be placed
into a specimen bag and removed through
one of the ports at the end of the
procedure the laparoscope and surgical
instruments will be removed a port valve
will be left in place briefly to allow
the gas to escape from the abdomen the
incisions will be closed with sutures
followed by skin glue or skin closure
tape
if your appendix can't be removed
laparoscopically your surgeon will
switch to an open procedure reasons for
switching to an open procedure include
an extensive infection or abscess a
perforated appendix which means there's
a hole in it
obesity dents scar tissue from previous
abdominal surgery difficulty viewing the
organs with the laparoscope and bleeding
problems during the operation
an open appendectomy is done directly
through a slightly larger abdominal
incision over your appendix or through a
lower middline incision as needed
the surgeon will tie off the appendix
with sutures and remove it then the
incision will be closed with sutures or
staples